let's take one or two more calls we may
have time for let's next go to our
caller from the 971 area code caller
what's your name and where you're
calling from hi my name is Jude and I'm
calling from Portland Oregon awesome
what's on your mind I was just curious
what your opinions were on the alt-right
in my opinion I feel like they're kind
of using like memes as a new form of
propaganda yeah we we did I couldn't
possibly sum up my views in this sort of
shorter format we did about a 20 minute
more in-depth exposé called the truth
about the alt-right and it outlines my
views Wow way more in a more detailed
fashion than I could possibly do now we
do address though I will mention the
aspect of the sort of Mema fication of
politics that you're pointing to and I
would encourage you to check that out on
our youtube channel youtube.com slash
the david pakman show we really dig into
the entire thing
oh wow totally
and well thank you that all right
appreciate the call oh I hit the hang-up
button before I realized he was asking
that that second question I apologize
about that unfortunately because of the
limitations of Technology there's no way
that I can
unhand right now rachel is cringing but
I hit the button before I heard that I
mean you can attest to that right yeah
there's no one question policy
thankfully we don't have a one-question
policy now I would have gladly taken a
second question